last thing sort of tangentially related
to covet
a number of you sent to me an
extraordinarily disturbing video of
failed former president donald trump's
former national security adviser michael
flynn a guy who was of course convicted
by uh
after being uh indicted um
michael flynn
it's sort of like it come just comes out
he can't even control it it's like a
diarrhea of the mouth
an incredible conspiracy word salad
involving dna altering covet shots
and yuval harari the author
wanting to turn people into cyborgs with
robotic components this is really full
on and i want you to remember two things
number one at one point this was the top
national security official in the
country
and this is the stuff that he is now
saying and number two
um
they
continue the the folks that were
initially saying we know the most about
this covet thing
continue to say things this outlandish
listen to this they are trying to change
the very essence of our dna and there
are people working on this that's one of
them you've all know a harare which
which is just not going to work now by
the way
just as a coincidence
you've all know a harare who wrote
sapiens
and who wrote homo deus and some other
really great books
he just so happens to be israeli right
he just so happens that he's jewish
um i know that they often criticize that
it's often true that the people they
pull into these conspiracy theories
aren't jewish
but a whole heck of a lot of them are
and they mentioned klaus schwab and they
mentioned george soros and now now
you've all know a harare is the target
of it's these people are pathetic so
what do they do they're going to
basically put components of robotics
into us wow that's one of the other
issues that they are looking at so you
know everything from you see the robotic
arms which can help somebody or robotic
legs which can help somebody who lost
their legs or somebody who lost their
movement of their arm or an arm to be
able to do things and to live like a
normal life but those are that's
different than what these guys are
trying to do they're actually trying to
change inside the internals of something
that is unchangeable unmovable immovable
because they're designed by someone
other than them and thank god
that god designed us the way we are
you can't even possibly unpack that i
mean i'm not even going to try to unpack
the substance of it that is bonkers
stuff
this is a guy who should be in a psych
ward or in prison now he you know he was
pardoned by trump so
he was the national security adviser of
the united states understand that
understand the the
uh teetering over the brink position
that the united states was in with guys
like this and trump claimed he would
hire the best people he needs
professional help
and trump put him at the top position
for national security in the country
this guy is leading anyone we have a
serious problem and now it is just a
word salad of dna covid yuval harari
cyborg robotic components god designed
us
scary stuff we should consider that we
dodged a bullet in a sense that flynn
didn't last that long as national
security advisor let me know what you
think find me on twitter at deepakman